wenn zwei philosophen sich treffen ist
es am vernünftigsten wenn sie einander
bloß guten morgen sagen
das behauptete jean paul sartre wir
treten heute an mit dem vorsatz das
gegenteil zu beweisen und zwar mit einem
neuen format dem philosophischen
stammtisch herzlich willkommen
alle zwei monate wagen die in der
sternstunde philosophie einen
philosophischen wochenrückblick und
diskutieren mit drei philosophen die
wichtigsten themen der vergangenen tage
heute sind dies die flüchtlingskrise und
donald trump unsere stammgäste sind
jeweils kathrin numark aus berlin
sie ist philosophin und
kulturjournalistin unter anderem für
deutschlandradio kultur
stammgast ist auch konrad paul liessmann
er ist professor für philosophie und der
universität wien und neben vielem
anderen monatlicher kolumnist der nz
zu unseren stammgästen stößt ein
weiterer philosoph dieses mal ist dies
andreas kast er stammt aus zürich
arbeitet zurzeit an der freien
universität berlin
er setzt sich seit vielen jahren mit
ethik und migration auseinander
herzlich willkommen ihnen an jaja
liessmann österreich hat als erstes land
in europa eine obergrenze für
flüchtlinge beschlossen hatten sie
diesen entscheid für richtig
gleich befürchtet dass ich mir diese
frage stellen werden
ich muss gestehen ich habe keine
eindeutige antwort darauf der erste
moralische impuls nachdem bisschen
nachricht mich erreicht hat war
natürlich das abzulehnen
aus dem bekannten argument dass es für
bestimmte moralische verpflichtungen ja
keine quantitativen grenzen obergrenzen
wie auch immer geben kann
auf der anderen seite realpolitisch
gesehen denke ich diese entscheidung
durchaus vertretbar es gibt eine ganze
reihe auch wichtiger migrationsforscher
die das vorgeschlagen haben natürlich
nicht für ein einzelnes land sondern für
ein gesamteuropäisches konzept das heißt
das ist etwas was durchaus diskutabel
ist und dann denke ich kommt doch auch
sehr darauf an wie diese obergrenze
definiert ist als österreich hat sich
bereit erklärt jährlich etwas über 30
35.000 menschen aufzunehmen
man hätte es auch anders formulieren
können man hätte es als mindestgrenze
formulieren können zum beispiel auf alle
fälle ist aber österreich sozusagen der
einzige stadt die seriöser in europa der
deklariert hat ja was er beitragen kann
was er beitragen will zur lösung dieses
konflikts und wieviel menschen wie
vielen menschen wie er ein faires
asylverfahren anbieten können
bei einer aufnahme quote zwischen 40 und
60 prozent nach den erfahrungen heißt
das auch dass gewisse anzahl von
menschen sicher sein kann würde ja dass
er muss kurz durchgerechnet der würde
jedes europäische land gemessen an
seiner einwohnerzahl oder auch nur noch
seinem bruttosozialprodukt eine ähnliche
quote festlegen hätten wir keine
flüchtlingskrise sondern vielleicht eine
flüchtlingsfrage etwa der frage der
integration und dergleichen mehr
aber wir hätten nicht diese angespannte
lage was ich nun einsatz was ich an
österreich kritisiere ist tatsächlich
der art und weise wie das dann
exekutiert worden ist wie die balkan
konferenz abgelaufen ist dass man
griechenland draußen gelassen hat das
halt die für politisch nicht klug sind
schon ganz viele themen auf dem tisch
etwas was ich raus höre ist an sich
könnte man über obergrenzen diskutieren
aber es ist in einem gesamteuropäischen
setting müsste das passieren von numark
dass ich das tatsächlich eine frage die
jetzt auf dem tisch liegt laut tagen im
moment ist natürlich vor allem
griechenlands war stauen sich die
flüchtlinge wenn man da so plakativ
sagen darf
25.000 menschen sind da man sagt es
könnte in den nächsten wochen an stellen
bis auf hunderttausend flüchtlinge jetzt
hier diskutiert auf europäischer ebene
einen hilfsfonds zu öffnen über 700
millionen euro die dann verteilt werden
sollen auf solche länder wie
griechenland aber ganz grundsätzlich
gefragt schulden sei es sich denn die
einzelnen staaten gegenseitig
gerechtigkeit also dass ich würde nur
ganz kurz nach ihrer frage vielleicht
eingreifen und sagen leid tragen sind
waren die flüchtlinge aber natürlich ist
es im europäischen kontext so dass
griechenland jetzt in der vor einem
massiven problem steht und diese
normative frage ob sich staaten
gegenseitig gerechtigkeit schulden
natürlich tun sie das man kann das sehr
gut argumentieren mit john rawls oder so
aber ich würde sagen realpolitisch ist
es doch meistens so dass staaten nach
ihren interessen handeln und daran hat
und das ist ja die wirklich leidvolle
erfahrung der letzten monate und jahre
auch im zusammenhang mit den
flüchtlingen auch europa nicht so viel
geändert
und natürlich kann man dann sagen es
gibt sehr viele gebote der politischen
klugheit dass man griechenland nicht
alleine lässt vor allem weil man eben
weiß wie da die situation der
flüchtlinge auch aussieht also diese
humanitäre katastrophe die wir die uns
immer näher rückt sozusagen von jenseits
des mittelmeeres jetzt auf dem
mittelmeer und jetzt sozusagen in
unserem urlaubsparadies und die wir
einfach auch nicht mehr ansehen können
das heißt es gibt viele gebote der
politischen klugheit griechenland da
nicht alleine zu lassen
aber ob wir das jetzt mit einer
normativen instanz im sinne von wir
schulden griechenland gerechtigkeit wer
würde denn so etwas durchsetzen
das finde ich jetzt interessant sie
beide haben das stichwort realismus
erwähnt also diese idee dass politik als
mit pragmatischen grundsätzen zu
verteidigen ist und man nicht so sehr
mit moralischen grundsätzen politik
machen kann
herr kasse von ihnen weiß ich dass sie
das vermutlich ziemlich anders sehen sie
haben zum beispiel gesagt in einem
interview mit sf kultur dass wir im
vornherein geführt haben
obergrenzen hatten sie hier ähnlich
hochwertig
ja ich bin zunächst mal muss man
festhalten dass diese obergrenzen
eindeutig gegen internationales recht
verstoßen das hat jetzt auch die eu
kommission noch mal gesagt dass wenn
menschen in österreich auf dem
territorium sich befinden oder an der
grenze aufgegessen werden dann haben sie
in richtung asyl zu ersuchen
und österreich muss höchsten ob dieses
asyl gesucht ob dem stattzugeben ist
jetzt kann österreich natürlich geltend
machen wir müssen das europäische und
das verteilen und so weiter das ist
völlig legal aber einfach zu sagen bei
uns wir haben jetzt unsere obergrenze
erreicht wir nehmen keine asylgesuche
mehr entgegen das ist eine
menschenrechtsverletzung und zwar nicht
nur in einem moralischen sondern auch in
einem rechtlich verbrieften sinne und
ich finde das wird manchmal so ein
bisschen klein geredet wir verletzen
damit die genfer flüchtlingskonvention
das finde ich schon gefährlich nur ein
kurzer satz meines wissens ist das
ziemlich umstritten
diese position in österreich ist nur von
sicheren staaten umgeben das heißt also
keiner der für österreichs grenze steht
ist tatsächlich in dem land in dem er
steht das kann nur italiens sein das
kann das vor ihnen sein das könnte
ungarn sein
ist er tatsächlich bedroht ja das heißt
also wir haben hier dieses große problem
dass sozusagen die idee von dublin 3
nicht mehr gilt aber wir da dafür oder
stelle dessen nicht wirklich einen
ersatz gefunden haben und ich habe so
ein bisschen ein problem wenn von seiten
der eu kommission hier kritik geübt wird
in einer praxis die dann was die
realität entspricht der für die
flüchtlinge in der wesentlich
hilfreicher praxis als diejenigen von
staaten die sich zwar formal zu seinem
moralischen prinzip bekennen aber
niemanden aufnehmen ja also diesen
widerspruch hätte ich schon auch gern
mal auf den tisch gelegt und diskutiert
das scheint mir ja auch das zu sein wo
wir alle unsere grenzen kommen sowohl
unserer denkt als auch unsere politik
fähigkeit die art und weise wie sich
moralische fragen mit pragmatischen
fragen vermischen in dieser
flüchtlingskrise dass man eben sehr wohl
prinzipien hat und auch ideen aber dass
auch die pragmatische umsetzung also
unten ist eben dringlich die es nicht in
fünf jahren wichtig sondern jetzt morgen
übermorgen weil da wirklich leute an
grenzen stehen dass diese umsetzung
nicht funktioniert das heißt selbst wenn
man sich einige könnte in europa was mir
sehr weit weg erscheint und selbst wenn
man diese einigung erreichen würde hätte
man ja immer noch ein riesiges
pragmatisches problem und diese
vermischung von moralischen prinzipien
und sozusagen der umsetzbarkeit
derselben das ist ja das woran gerade
alle verzweifelt
ich möchte ihnen die gelegenheit geben
noch zu replizieren haben glaube ich
gerade vorhin noch einfach sagen waren
zu dem was ja ich werde einfach was die
rechtliche situation angeht ist es so
dass wenn jemand an der grenze
aufgegriffen wird unter der kontrolle in
diesem fall österreich steht hat die
person das recht zu sagen ich möchte
asyl beantragen jetzt ist die frage
dürfen sie diese person push back mäßig
zurückschieben das europäische recht
klar wenn die andere personen im rahmen
eines dublin-verfahren sagt ja wir sind
jetzt zuständig das asyl gesucht
durchzuführen
zuerst hat sie das einfach quasi mit
physischer gewalt leute die um asyl
ansuchen aus den staatsgrenzen
wegzudrängen ohne sicherzustellen dass
irgendwo ein asylgesuch stellen können
das ist eine menschenrechtsverletzung
das ist das eine das ist diese
rechtliche diskussion das andere was
mich an der aktuellen debatte stört
erste mobile philosophische ebene geht
ist natürlich kann man sich fragen wie
viele flüchtlinge kommen österreich oder
irgendeinem anderen europäischen staaten
aber solche frage nach den grenzen des
zumutbaren die kann man halt immer von
zwei seiten her stellten also können
weges zwischen flüchtlingen zumuten dass
wir von ihnen erwarten dass die unter
lebensgefahr in zügen bleiben oder dass
sie ohne jede perspektive in den
überfüllten flüchtlingslagern im libanon
oder in jordanien bleiben und ich bin
wenn es uns ernst ist mit der gleichheit
aller menschen dann müssen wir werden
eine perspektive einnehmen die beides
ernst nimmt die rolle des europäischen
bürgers aber auch die rolle des
jüdischen flüchtlings und wir müssen
erst die positionen vertreten von denen
wir denken wir könnten die auch gut
heißen wenn wir selbst in der rolle des
jüdischen flüchtlings wege sie wird dann
sind wir von dieser obergrenzen
diskussion sehr weit und 17 jahren stück
weit für einen perspektivenwechsel also
lasst lasst uns sozusagen in den kopf
des syrischen flüchtlings steigen und
uns überlegen was wäre für den zu
rechtfertigen
ein stück weit ist natürlich die
aussagen ein widerspruch vielleicht
besteht dazu zu dem was rüdiger
verfahrens kinder ein zurzeit am sonntag
betont hat auch ein philosoph der gesagt
hat die idee der souveränen staaten ist
gerade dass die ihre grenzen sichern und
verteidigen und das die sagen hier ist
unser land so und so viele leute haben
hier platz
und wir können die grenzen eben noch zu
machen
das ist dieses alte westfälische bild
von absoluter staatlicher souveränität
ich denke spätestens mitte mai eine
erklärung der menschenrechte ist man von
absoluter souveränität weggekommen
um was mich jetzt erstaunt ich meine ich
würde ja gerne noch weiter von diesem
souveränitäts gedanken wegkommen ich
persönlich glaube dass wir langfristig
ohnehin offene grenzen anstreben sollten
aber was jetzt passiert ist dass man
dahinter zurück geht
worauf man sich vertraglich geeinigt hat
nämlich politisch verfolgte menschen das
recht zu geben einen asylantrag zu
stellen und deshalb finde ich das ist
nicht so wenig zeit sondern das ist ein
zurückgehen hinter den bisherigen
menschenrechtlichen konsens vielleicht
nur eine anmerkung da zunächst das
problem völlig klar und auch die
philosophische oder ethische position
die wir hier oder menschenrechtliche
position die man hier vertreten kann ja
nur wir haben auf der anderen seite ist
schon auch mit dem phänomen zu tun dass
das asylrecht so wir sind es über rechts
konvention festgelegt worden ist ja
gegenseitig nicht mehr sagen
interpretiert wird er sondern politische
verfolgung zum beispiel der genfer
flüchtlingskonvention schloss ja etwa
krieg als flüchtlings oder fluchtgrund
aus ja politische verfolgung das waren
zeiten des kalten krieges konzipiert
worden war wirklich gedacht für menschen
die persönliches individuellen ja nicht
sozusagen als ein brot das kollektiv
sondern die als individuellen aufgrund
ihrer politischen ansicht aufgrund ihrer
ethnischen zugehörigkeit aufgrund ihrer
religionszugehörigkeit als individuum
verfolgt sind und dieses asylrecht
glaube es sollte wirklich jetzt großes
wort heilig sein ja das ist ganz
wesentliche errungenschaft aber
gegenwärtig habe ich schon den eindruck
und die zahlen des statistischen zeigen
ist ja auch dass man unter dem titel
asylrecht etwas machen wie was ganz was
anderes ist meiner ansicht nach nicht
migrationspolitik dafür ist das
asylrecht nicht gedacht ja und natürlich
kann jetzt lange darüber diskutiert
haben wir zwei möglichkeiten entweder
wir geben uns die möglichkeit zwischen
asylgründe und anderen migrations
gründen zu unterscheiden und sagen für
die eines asylrecht zuständig da gilt
diese unbedingte pflicht der
hilfeleistung und der schutzwürdigkeit
und für das andere gelten sozusagen die
migrations regeln die sich alle staaten
gewisser weise geben und auf die sie
sich verpflichten und einen können
oder wir sagen diese differenz zwischen
politischer verfolgung und flucht aus
ökonomischen gründen aus kriegs- gründen
aus ökologischen gründen müssen wir auch
leben das gibt nicht mehr
das heißt dann mal in großem stil
wanderung und migrationspolitik dann
dafür wie man nicht mehr auf diese
vorhaben des asylrechts das auf
individuelle politisch verfolgt der
rekurrierte mich argumentativ beziehen
dann muss ich auch farbe bekennen ja ich
finde den punkt interessant wenn sie das
erwähnte es geht um individuelle
politische verfolgte
und letztlich glaube ich dass diese art
von asyl gleich natürlich immer sich
sodann weiter entwickelt anhand der
situation ich habe letzte entweder mal
mit großem interesse hannah arendts
aufsatz the fugees gelesen wo sie einen
neuen typus des flüchtlings ausmacht
nämlich den der eben nicht aufgrund
seiner individuellen politischen
einstellung oder sagen daher
individuellen politischen handlung ein
flüchtling wird sondern auch seiner
ethnischen zugehörigkeit also die
europäischen juden im zweiten weltkrieg
und dieser neue typus den versucht sie
dann einzuordnen und der ist neu und ich
glaube das ist genau der ist jetzt in
diesem asylrecht schon drin jetzt kommen
wir aber doch offensichtlich an einen
punkt wo wir wieder einen neuen typus
definieren müssen und ich glaube nicht
dass wir zumal im syrien konflikt
wirklich einfach das über migration
regeln können also es gibt konflikte und
kriegsherr de
die sind so grausam dass wir tatsächlich
wahrscheinlich einen asylsuchenden neuen
typus auch der gehen müssen und stelle
würde ich auch gerne ein haken weil das
ist jetzt auch eine sehr realistische
diskussion die wir führen wenn ihr uns
einfach mal noch einmal vor augen führen
den allermeisten geht es also wenn sie
diese bilder sehen gerade auch
beispielsweise bilder jetzt an der
grenze zu mazedonien flüchtlinge
menschen die mit dem mit tüchern bedeckt
sind wenn sie frieren kinder frauen die
da an den zäunen rütteln
da denkt man ja einfach klar diesen
menschen muss man schutz gewähren egal
was jetzt das völkerrecht erstmal sagt
gleichzeitig gibt es auch ganz viele
menschen die sagen diese befürchtung
haben wir werden hier überrollt wir
haben keinen platz mehr mit unserer
kultur wie soll das alles aufgehen auch
ökonomisch und wir haben unsere
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer eingeladen
auch ihre ideen ihre vorschläge ihre
kommentare uns zu schicken
in diesem zusammenhang würde ich gerne
einen kommentar von peter escher aus
leuth stadt einbringen der fragt wo
bleibt das recht eines jeden bürgers in
seinem land menschenwürdig weiter reden
zu können
der kasse was sagen sie dazu also
selbstverständlich hat jeder mensch in
europa das recht menschenwürdig zu leben
die frage ist nur gibt es einen kausalen
zusammenhang zwischen der aufnahme von
flüchtlingen und menschenwürde
verletzungen in europa und da muss man
schon sagt dass ich mein erstes ist es
nicht so dass wir quasi unser gesamtes
stattliches budget für das asylwesen
haus geben und jetzt plötzlich keine
altersheime und spitäler mehr für die
eigenen bürgerinnen und bürgern hätten
wir geben ganz viel geld auch aus für
dinge die nicht direkt für den schutz
der menschenwürde da sind also wir haben
beispielsweise in der schweiz gerade
beschlossen ein zweites loch durch das
gotthardmassiv zu boden und ich finde
schon interessant dass bei dieser
diskussion niemand sagt wo bleibt die
menschenwürde der räumen wenn wir jetzt
milliarden ausgehen und loch durch das
gotthardmassiv zu bogen aber sobald man
ein bisschen mittel für flüchtlinge
brauch kommt sofort dieses argument wo
bleibt die menschenwürde der eigenen
bürgerinnen und bürger ich finde das
schon von populistischer vergiftung des
klimas also darf ich noch ganz kurz
nachhaken ich möchte trotzdem vielleicht
noch eine zweite frage stellen viele
zuschauer fragen und ich möchte mich an
dieser stelle auch bedanken für die
vielen zuschriften die eingegangen sind
die fragen ist das boot den gar nie
vorher kasse also ich würde sagen wenn
man ernsthaft eine situation käme in der
die öffentliche ordnung
zusammenzubrechen droht in der die
menschenrechte der bisherigen
bewohnerinnen und bewohner eines
territoriums in gefahr berge
darum sind restriktionen möglicherweise
zulässig ich glaube einfach dass solche
situationen allenfalls bei gewissen form
von süd migration neuwagen ich man muss
sich bewusst sein beispielsweise im
libanon gibt es jetzt eine million
flüchtlinge auf rund vier millionen
einwohner ich meine dass an solchen
punkten dann wirklich schwierige fragen
kommen wie geht man mit diesen
abweichungen um das sehe ich bleibe nur
dass wir in europa wirklich nicht an dem
punkt sind ja und ich glaube tatsächlich
auch dass der libanon das ist ja
wirklich gefahr und ich glaube dass man
natürlich sagen man muss diesen leuten
helfen das heißt auch nicht dass wir
sagen dass wir
auf langfrist auf lange frist alle
menschen aus syrien nach deutschland
oder in die schweiz übersiedeln aber ich
glaube schon dass man sozusagen etwas
mit also es geht um direkthilfe es geht
um die erleichterung einer situation
jetzt und es geht natürlich darum dass
man auch vor ort also auch diese
flüchtlingslager endlich wieder mal ein
bisschen ordentlich finanziert haben
sich die staaten jetzt dazu
durchgerungen nach dem plötzlichen
herztod ausgeblieben ist also es geht
natürlich darum dass man sich
verantwortlich fühlt und ich glaube
natürlich wie herr kasse dass wir eine
obergrenze hierzulande von zulässigen
sozusagen dem zuwanderern oder
asylanträgen noch nicht erreicht haben
aber ich glaube selbst wenn unser
territorium selbst wenn wir wie der
libanon ein viertel unserer bevölkerung
und ein fünftel plötzlich flüchtlinge
wären würden wir immer noch und wir
sagen müssen wir können keine aufnahmen
werden wir immer noch verantwortlich für
das was in unserer umwelt passiert und
diese verantwortung ernst zu nehmen also
dieses nicht mehr den kopf in den sand
stecken weil die leute die sterben im
wesentlichen jenseits des mittelmeers
sterben wo wir auf grund von grants
zäunen und mittelmeer patronen nicht hin
blicken müssen das ist etwas das ist
eigentlich das was neu ist dass die
leute sterben jenseits des mittelmeers
das ist lange schon so aber dass wir
irgendwie keine entschuldigung mehr
haben das zu verdrängen
und dass wir irgendwie auch wenn wir in
unseren gesellschaften funktionale
wirtschaftliche und kulturelle systeme
bewahren wollen dafür mitverantwortlich
sein wissen das ist globalisierung und
das passiert jetzt
sie haben ja in ihrer kolumne in der nz
in der letzten darauf aufmerksam gemacht
dass im moment sich so etwas wie eine
paradoxie entwickelt lange zeit war es
enorm populär gegen den staat zu wettern
der staat ist aufgebläht es gibt so viel
bürokratie
die steuern sind zu hoch und so weiter
das war fast schon ein gewissen kreisen
common sense und jetzt setz ich habe den
eindruck alles schreit nach dem start
entweder soll der staat gefälligst die
grenzen an ständig verteidigen oder
erstmal schauen dass rasch effizient
nachhaltig die flüchtlinge integriert
werden können haben wir gerade so etwas
wie auch ein neues wenn ich mal sagen
das bedürfnis gewisser weise schon wobei
ich jetzt staat nicht auf den
klassischen nationalstaat einschränke
seiner durch auch durchaus auch so
ungebildet wie die europäische union
mit meinen die ja auch sehr viel
sozusagen jetzt wünsche oder forderungen
herangetragen werden ja dass eine drückt
sich darin aus dass sehr viele sozusagen
das misslungene oder nicht wirklich
effizient gelungene management der
flüchtlingsströme auch ein
staatsversagen interpretiert haben also
steckt dahinter hoffentlich der wunsch
wäre hätte noch gerne einen staat nicht
der vielleicht jetzt diese grenzen
regierung ab regelt die aber da genau zu
sagen die infrastruktur stellt schnell
hilft der auch das know how hat durch
seine einheiten sinnvoll selbst städte
zu errichten und und hört der staat
versagt also da ist sozusagen wirklich
dass er diese vorstellung bedeute dass
die durch das mehr staatlicher
handlungen und auf der anderen seite
kann man natürlich sagen dass der staat
das ist bei der fdp sie vertreten mit in
seinem bisherigen rechts vorstellung und
rechtsordnungen vielleicht gar nicht
mehr in der lage ist sehr bringt sie
aber nicht in der lage ist mit diesen
herausforderungen umzugehen und wir uns
vielleicht noch völlig anderen oder
neuen formen von rechts zuständen unter
denen sich menschen organisieren können
umsehen müssen das heißt dass ein
prinzipielles starts skepsis die sich
hier zum ausdruck bringt und ich glaube
die europäische union hat er ja das
problem dass sie weder das eine noch das
andere ist ja das heißt dass es wäre
natürlich sinnvoll gewesen von anfang an
also genau diese fragen schon vor jahren
nicht zu verdrängen
das völlig richtig festgestellt haben
ist natürlich sinnvoll gewesen die ganz
europa dazu einstellen darauf
vorbereiten was bedeutet die
schengengrenze kann die auch die grenze
sein die einerseits weder sozusagen
irgendeine abgeschottete regierung
darstellt noch nur noch auf dem papier
ist dann kann es der grenze seien an der
also etwa natürlich versuchen durch
schon einen antrag stellen können und
nicht gezwungen sind kreuz und quer
durch den kontinent zu ihren hätte man
so ein grenzmanagement nicht schon als
europäische konzeption vor 123 jahren
ins auge fassen können aber dass sie
nicht dass in fragen des ihr wieder
daran stellen
wie sehr kann so ein supranationales
super staatliches gebilde gleichsam in
diesen staatlichen rechtsordnung
reagieren er ich wollte eben gerade
nachfragen was die neuen gebiete wären
die man sich denken ist aber ich glaube
sie haben das
tatsächlich ja auch schon ausgeführte
ist natürlich finde ich hatte finde ich
das im moment der staat gefragt das sind
der weise dass wir natürlich eine
öffentliche ordnung die uns wichtiges
aufrechterhalten müssen gerade weil die
diskussion in deutschland zumindest
nicht dass er stark so war sehr stark
kultur allis tisch geführt wird also ist
ein problem unserer kultur und wir
müssen leute integrieren in unsere
kultur und man könnte eine gegenposition
ein nehmen und sagen das müssen wir gar
nicht unbedingt wir müssen nur leute
integrieren in unserer staatliche
ordnung und diese ordnung muss
garantiert werden als es braucht eine
genügend starke und robuste sozusagen
sicher innere sicherheit dass wenn so
seien im moment auftaucht wo ein chaos
ausbricht wo es zu unschönen situationen
kommt eine polizei auch genügend
einsatzkräfte hat das zu unterbinden und
das sowohl an den grenzen als auch im
innenleben und natürlich ist das nicht
konfliktfrei wenn man plötzlich eine
sehr große anzahl von migranten die
keinen job haben und frustriert sind bei
sich hat aber das heißt es geht um ein
das aufrechterhalten einer staatlichen
ordnung und ich würde sagen viel weniger
um das auch nicht erhalten einer kultur
der immer so herbeigerufen ist aber
selbst auch sehr vage ist was ist in
unserer kultur und unserer wäre sie
bilden auch in diesem punkt nicht
rüdiger safranski will nicht noch einmal
zitieren möchte zustimmen der sagte wir
haben ein problem mit der integration
weil wir uns davor scheuen wieder von
einer leitkultur zu sprechen wir haben
immer gleich das gefühl das ist
rechtsradikal aber eigentlich müssten
die wieder unsere identität bestimmen
ungarn sinnvoll integrieren zu können
dass ich halte dieses identität sein
argument für total verheerend also
natürlich geht es
man kann man das identität nennen wenn
man sagt es gibt gewisse
rechtsprinzipien und gewisse politik
prinzipien auf die wir uns geeinigt
haben
aber sobald man das sozusagen kultur
realistisch auflädt und und an wert der
traditionen die spezifisch deutsch oder
spezifisch schweizerisch sind bindet
dann kommt man dem teufels küche was
wären die denn
und ich glaube nicht dass es darum geht
es geht ja auch nicht darum dass wir
jetzt irgendwie hundert tausend syrer zu
deutschen machen es geht darum dass wir
hunderttausende syrer in deutschland
erleben erlauben so zu leben dass sie
sich in deutschland ein menschenwürdiges
leben leben können dass sie die deutsche
sprache lernen einen job finden und dann
mit der zeit ihrer gegnerin deutsche
sein und die rinder werden
wahrscheinlich deutscher sein und das
ist dann auch okay aber es geht ja nicht
darum dass man
heute kulturell assimiliert ich würde
gerne vielleicht noch einmal einen
kommentar einbringen und zwar von oliver
lacroix frankfurt am main er schreibt
viele dachten lange zeit noch von
auschwitz her entschlossen so etwas
niemals mehr zuzulassen dass wir so viel
mehr zu verlieren haben als turnhallen
und ein prozent wirtschaftswachstum was
haben viele von uns heute vergessen
teilen sie diese einschätzung kassel ja
also ich glaube auch dass diese verluste
hengste oft ziemlich übertrieben sind
und ich würde das sehr ähnlich sehen wie
sie das so die migration und dass sich
politik ein stück weit ja auch so das
letzte bollwerk schauten vorstellung ist
dass wir quasi so von oben unsere
kollektive kultur festlegen und der
staat sorgt das ist die religion unseres
landes und das ist der musikstil unseres
landes und das ist der kleidungsstil
unseres landes und in allen anderen
bereichen haben wir uns durch längst zu
der idee bekommt dass es jeder einzelnen
person überlassen ist welche kleidung
sie tragen möchte welcher region sie
praktizieren möchte und so weiter also
wenn eine person welche kulturelle
entscheidungen macht die unsere
mitbürgerinnen ist dann fragt nie jemand
ist das eine kulturelle belastung für
das land sondern man denkt einfacher
freiheitsrechte und es ist schon
interessant dass migrations und
asylpolitik sei der einzige heute ist wo
das noch anders aussieht
ich halte das jetzt mal für
überzeichnung ja also ich stimme völlig
zu wichtig wäre sozusagen eine
rechtsordnung die klar ist die
transparent ist und auf die migranten
aus welchen gründen auch immer sie
kommen verpflichten kann
ich habe mich auch sozusagen in einem
kommentar in der nz gegen diese
sozusagen werte die füße wertediskussion
ausgesprochen
genauso sehe ich das auch die kultur
betrifft nur eines ich glaube nicht dass
das der status quo ist ja ich glaube
dazu sagen dass diese diese vorstellung
dass der staat sozusagen festlegt war
setzt unsere kultur ist und welchen stil
lest ihr hier verbindlich sehen die
vertreter fast niemanden ja das ist auch
nicht das ausdrücklich als gemeint hat
obwohl ich in dem punkt mit ihnen nicht
übereinstimmen kann auf eine leitkultur
gut verzichten
philosophisch interessiert sich nur
folgendes paradoxon wir sagen von uns ja
kulturelle identität ist jetzt nicht so
dass wahnsinnig wichtiges darauf kann
man gut und gerne verzichten
viele dinge die entscheidende sinn und
wir sagen dass deshalb damit menschen zu
uns kommen genau diese kulturelle
identität leben können
denn die kommen nämlich dass individuen
nicht nur individuen die kommen schon
als angehörige eines tatsächlich ganz
ganz mitunter stark geprägten
kulturellen identität verstehen also es
verstehen so lade ich sagen so zu sagen
wir betonen kultur ist nicht so wichtig
damit wir auf unsere verzichten gestehen
diese aber den anderen zu mir natürlich
ist der hauptgrund dafür dass wir
natürlich dass man sagen können dass in
deren tradition mit diesem hintergrund
aus dieser religion ist anordnung tätig
ist sagt ja immer dass wir seit dieses
paradox richtig stört so lange überhaupt
nicht das tatsächliche dies klassisch
liberal bürgerlichen sinne verstanden
werden kann
als individuum soll jeder sich klein
glauben tun und lassen was er will
solange die rechtsordnung nicht angreift
wenn es aber zu dem selbstverständnis
des menschen gehört einer anderen
rechtsordnungen gruppe anzugehören ja
dann geht es für nicht problematisch
also und das kann man einfach nicht
leugnen das kann man ja es gibt
sozusagen diese diese
parallelgesellschaften es gibt diese
subkulturen gern der mitglieder den
mitgliedern sozusagen klar ist dass die
scharia im grunde wichtiger ist es die
bundesverfassung
das mag es geben ich glaube tatsächlich
aber nicht dass das die asylsuchenden
und die flüchtlinge in ihren großen teil
betrifft weil da geht es natürlich um
eine andere intention dann geht es um
das fliegen element ändern sofern das
situation ja an der situation klar
und ich glaube dass teure wir reden auch
über langfristige integrations
perspektiven also da würde ich wiederum
sagen
syrien ist in seiner tradition er als
säkulares land wenn man sieht dass auch
an den zahlen an den einstellungen an
den bildungs verhältnissen der syrischen
flüchtlinge
das ist glaube ich nicht das problem was
uns zu gestehen bevorsteht und ich
glaube natürlich geht es nicht darum
dass der staat etwas definiert aber wir
haben es geht auch nicht um so ein
falsch verstanden und kulturrelativismus
also dass unsere kultur ist es nicht so
wichtig aber wir geben denen völlige
religionsfreiheit als natürlich es geht
um sozusagen eine individualistische
oder meinetwegen auch subkulturell
organisiert das kulturverständnis ist
mir zum beispiel ist feminismus oder
homosexuellen
total wichtig und ich habe freunde die
total anarchistisch sind und so weiter
und die müssen irgendwie leben können
und das ist total wichtig und das muss
es geben
ich habe einen etwas minderen respekt
vor sehr religiösen menschen aber ich
lasse die auch in meinem land leben also
es gibt sozusagen schon darum dass diese
position als gleichwertig und auch
gleichermaßen wie möglich dargestellt
werden also dieser individualismus den
sie erwähnt haben natürlich kann man
auch so kulturellen group is muss
irgendwie fassen
aber das heißt nicht dass der sich
aufgibt zugunsten dessen dass jetzt da
menschen kommt die strengere
sittenstrenge forscher werden ja im
grunde genommen beim stichwort der
toleranz dass wir sagen wir müssen als
kern der idee unserer kultur die
toleranz stark machen und entsprechend
tolerant mit anderen überzeugung umgehen
und toleranz ist robust also wollte er
schon sagte den fanatikern wird der kopf
abgeschlagen also das ist versteh von
toleranz ist da das wiederholen also
keine toleranz ist eine robuste tugend
als ergebnis sehr stark darum dass um
das abwehren von intoleranz und ich
finde das problem dieser dieses
kulturellen aufladens von problemen die
wirklich gesund rechtsprobleme sind ist
roman quasi wo man den schnee gesetzt in
anführungszeichen weil meine wahrnehmung
ist dass die allermeisten muslime in der
schweiz beispielsweise gerne in einem
land leben in dem grundrechte gelten und
die respektieren und dann gibt es eine
ganz kleine minderheit die
möglicherweise fundamentalistische
einstellungen hat so wie es übrigens
auch immer noch fundamentalistische
gästen geht und jetzt hat man aber die
politische situation in der dem
irgendwie derart pauschal dem islam
unterstellt wird mit dem liberalen
rechtsstaat unvereinbar zu sein dass
dann quasi diese 99 prozent der motor
garten muslime verunglimpft werden und
es schwierig gemacht wird auch innerhalb
dieser community ist den kampf gegen die
religiösen fundamentalisten zu führen
also ich finde dass da dass es da schon
wichtig ist quasi nicht so pauschale
vorverurteilungen zu machen alle muslime
wollen ja eigentlich die scharia statt
der grundrechte das hat niemand gesagt
na ja aber das ist rasiert durch
aktuelle und ich begann man muss schon
aufpassen dass man bestimmte formen von
kritik nicht dadurch sozusagen versucht
zu entschärfen dass man sagt die könnte
alle treffen
ja das hat niemand gesagt oder ich
zumindest
ich bin realist
es gibt ja ganze reihe von muslimischen
autoren die sagen das ist nicht nur ein
problem eines falsch verstandenen
radikalisierten islam sondern das ist da
steckt im islam selber drinnen
ich kann das von außen nicht beurteilen
ja ich kann nur sehen dass es auch
innerhalb der islamischen community
völlig unterschiedliche positionen
darüber gibt dazu sagen wie sehr jetzt
tatsächlich der islam hier prägend ist
und und und und substanziell eine andere
form eines seiner seines lebens
gleichsam beinhaltet die er mit
bestimmten grundrechtspositionen und vor
allem individualisierungs richten die
wir uns erkämpft haben nicht so einfach
vereinbar sehen was überhaupt nichts
dagegen sagt dass es unzählige menschen
geben hat muslimischen glaubens gott wir
in österreich kennen das neusser monate
zeit die bosnischen muslime waren
relativ liberal und säkularisiert und
sind auch sofort sozusagen als
religionsgemeinschaft gleich behandelt
werden wie die anderen
lebensgemeinschaften österreich oder
selters der islam gesetzt der
europäischen staaten hat das heißt also
das ist das ist das ist unbenommen
trotzdem muss auf der anderen seite sind
bestimmte konfliktfelder sehen und nicht
gleich so wieder auf die diskussion
nehmen indem man sagen jede kritik also
bevor vom vorbild darstellen ein letztes
kurzes und von newark dann möchte ich
zum nächsten thema okay ich wollte nur
sagen ja man muss diese sachen sehen und
man muss auch darin man muss man
vielleicht aber ein narrativ finden wo
man eben nicht so zu sein in diesem in
dieser zwiespalt von dozent wir und die
anderen und das misstrauen geht sondern
das narrativ ist dass man eben gemeinsam
vorwärts gehen muss es kommen
möglicherweise junge männer die wir
subjektiv als problematisch anders
empfinden und dann geht es darum dass
man eine kultur und ein kulturelles
narrativ erschafft wohin man eben
sozusagen mit unserer rechtsstaatlichen
form eine energiemenge eine
gemeinsamkeit findet wo man natürlich
gewisse dinge verbietet aber auch eine
chance gibt dieser öffnung und dieser
weiterentwicklung einer gesellschaft und
ich glaube das ist ebenso seien mit
einem diskurs des misstrauens nicht
herzustellen
gut wir müssen hier eine schneeschleuder
wir müssen einen schnitt machen wir
möchten zum zweiten thema gehen das
zweite thema das in diesen wochen für
schlagzeilen sorgte vor allem in diesen
tagen für schlagzeilen sorgte ist donald
trump die vorwahl
in den usa nach dem super tuesday
scheint relativ klar zu sein dass das
amt nominiert werden wird von den
republikanern für die us amerikanische
präsidentschaft sie lachen schon grau
newmark und genau darum soll es auch den
donald trump ist ja ein phänomen viele
bezeichnungen aus witzfigur waren
natürlich die politische unkorrektheit
sozusagen zu seinem markenzeichen macht
erhält foltermethoden wie waterboarding
für peanuts er möchte gerne die vielen
millionen von illegalen einwanderern in
den usa einfach wieder deckel aus weißem
er findet klimawandel ist schabernack
gleichstellung von mann und frau ist
nicht so wichtig und er hat kürzlich
auch ein mussolini zitat getwittert dass
er ein sehr schönes zitat fand also eine
ganze palette von dingen von denen wir
denken das kann doch gar nicht sein
viele haben ihn lange zeit auch als
clown bezeichnet der kasse haben wir
dann trump oder hat die usa den job
unterschätzt
ich denke dass die republikaner dort
wahrscheinlich lange unterschätzt haben
also die haben ja eine zeit lang fanden
sie jedes noch so wird die kategorische
mittel gegen obama zu schießen legitim
und dann hat man irgendwann gemerkt dass
das was wir drauf gebaut haben ist jetzt
in diesem verfahren nicht mehr zu
stoppen
was ich ganz interessant waren sind so
haub technologische untersuchungen
darüber welche persönlichkeitsmerkmale
eigentlich voraus traten erlauben
darüber wer trump unterstützt und dass
ein merkmal das da heraussticht ist
neigung zum autoritarismus also wenn man
leute fragt ist es ihnen beim kind
wichtiger dass es neugierig oder
gehorsam ist dann ist so dass diejenigen
leute die gehorsam teilen mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit ramp unterstützen und
das holt er natürlich auch mit dieser
politik alles fremde aus den usa
verhalten gegen innen mit harter hand
gegen abweichler vorgehen und so das ist
so ein auto wichtiges potenzial das da
abgeholt wird was natürlich sehr
gefährlich ist eigentlich ein stück weit
ist ja kommt sozusagen der paradefall
eines sogenannten populisten über
populismus redet man ja viel seit den
1980 er jahre josef joffe der
herausgeber der zeit hat in einem
kommentar geschrieben die müssen
aufpassen dass wir das phänomen nicht
auf ein amerikanisches phänomen alleine
sehen sondern populismus gibt es auch in
europa er sagt
beispielsweise was dem einen sein
mexikaner ist dem anderen sein muslim
hat er recht herzlich wird umgekehrt
sehen es ist ganz interessant dass man
plötzlich seine - populismus dass mehr
sehr lange als ein europäisches phänomen
und das ein phänomen zu sagen vor allem
von europäischen rechtsparteien gesehen
haben dass man das plötzlich auch in
amerika dem mutterland der demokratie
wieder entdeckt ja das ist für mich
sozusagen das erstaunliche ja natürlich
gab es voll bei den amerikanern immer
seltsame figuren ja es gab die oder es
gibt die tea party
es gab wie schauspieler des business
präsidentenamt geschafft haben über
deren politische beurteilung man ja
durchaus geteilter meinung sein kann
wenn man jetzt etwa 100 werken denkt das
heißt also diese dieser schillernden
figuren würde ich sagen gab es natürlich
alles gab nicht das was tatsächlich den
europäischen populismus auszeichnete aus
der ganzen historischen geschichte her
nicht ja und das finde ich mal
faszinierendes phänomen
oder es könnte natürlich auch sein dass
wir mit einer gewissen ratlosigkeit ist
ein phänomen trump gegenüberstellen und
jetzt das europäische konzept populismus
mit dem er schon viele politiker bedacht
hat jörg haider beim verteilen japan
sowohl vater als auch tochter ja also es
ist es gewohnt und wissen wir das heute
zu assoziieren haben und mit diesem
modell wenn man jetzt dann kramt einen
populisten nennt dann kann ich ein
wunderbar sofort einordnen und
vielleicht sollten ein bisschen genauer
hin blicken als ich bin mir eben auch
gar nicht sicher ob populismus mit
populismus trump so gut beschrieben
weil also wenn man sich sozusagen
gängige definition des populismus jetzt
auch im europäischen kontext es geht ja
immer darum dass man an negative
emotionen ängste appelliert an
ressentiments und die sind
offensichtlich in einem großen reservoir
vorhanden in der bevölkerung und mit
denen arbeitet man dann weiter mit einem
alleinvertretungsanspruch also man ist
eben der bahre volksvertreter und so
weiter es gibt ja sogar kriterien wo man
das ganz gut beschreiben kann und bei
kampf scheint mir natürlich macht er
auch diese ressentiments und ängsten auf
aber was eigentlich wesentliche zu sein
scheint
und was ich dann wiederum ein sehr
spezifisch amerikanisches phänomen finde
ist diese chirac kraftmeierei es gibt ja
von rumba der hat mal eine sehr schöne
sondern kulturell kultur analytischen
vignette beschriebenen unterschied
zwischen dem boxer und dem wrestler und
gesagt der wester das sind ja sozusagen
kämpfe wo ist die nicht eigentlich
ausgefochten werden sondern nur für show
sind und die sind aber da geht es um die
schiere energie des moments und die sind
darum nicht wert weniger ernsthaft dass
der boxkampf ist tatsächlich darum geht
wer gewinnt und bertram scheint dass er
genau so etwas zu sein die ihre energie
das moment also dieses wilde chaos was
er auslöst weil er überhaupt auch nicht
korrekt ist in seine position ist auch
kein klassischer sozusagen
rechtspopulist der nur sozusagen
rechtsextreme positionen bediente hat er
in manchen teilen auch ganz liberale
position und er äußert sich einfach
immer wieder also in der kindischen
freude an einem an einer anarchischen
freude irgendwie erwartungen zu
unterlaufen und extrem und korrektes zu
sagen ein stück weit hat er mich sehr
erinnert an dieses kleine buch von
haarig frankfurt amerikanischer
philosoph jean-paul schickt weil er in
diesem schmalen bändchen eigentlich
zusammenfasst was tram tut ohne sie
vorher gewusst zu haben alles glaubt was
man and around da noch nicht jemand der
bullshit der zählt ist eigentlich eine
person die gar nicht unbedingt die
unwahrheit sagt sondern die sich um
wahrheit schlicht zitiert man sagt man
das mal das spielt überhaupt keine rolle
die schau erzählt warum nehmen denn
leute trotzdem kaum so ernst also ich
meine die gegner nehmen er hat weil er
eine echte gefahr ist wenn niemand so
genau weiß was er machen wird wenn er
hat dinge angekündigt wie vor familien
von terroristen umbringen
offensichtliches kriegsverbrechen sagt
manchmal sogar ihn niemand weiß genau
bei sowas machen würde
warum ihn seine weiler so ernst nehmen
weiß ich nicht recht man in gewisser
weise ist es schon parallelen eigentlich
zu einer figur wie christoph blocher
also zum einen sehr gleicher mann der es
schafft so die wahrnehmung zu
produzieren dass sein reichtum seine
tatkraft beweist verbunden mit seiner
verachtung gegenüber der cross politik
und den politischen eliten auch das bei
bruchsal ganz wichtig dann so dieses
hass gegen minderheiten schülern alles
fremde fernhalten wollen
rechtsstaatlicher institutionen verhör
das ich sehe da eigentlich ganz gelangt
kann man wahrscheinlich schon sagen sind
proponenten der svp sehr viel stärker
eingebunden in einem interesse daran den
rechtsstaat aufrecht zu erhalten wo man
bei trump effektiv nicht mehr so ganz
sicher ist also ob die parallele so weit
geht das könnte man wahrscheinlich
diskutierbar also würde ich jetzt sage
ich weil die svp sagt ostendorf sie
schweizer recht über völkerrecht stellen
will und das würde heißen
man hält internationalen das ist ein
interessanter punkt was nicht missen von
einem intranet interessiert oder oder
auch fasziniert das ist auf der einen
seite wie es jemandem sie haben kurz
skizzierte der ecke zu seinen
klassischen unternehmertyp präsentiert
der sehr sehr reich ist ja der hat
exorbitant dass exzessives privatleben
in der öffentlichkeit gestellt hat ja
das so und dass es so jemanden gelingt
gerade die frustrierte so sagen
entrechtete arbeiterschaft für sich zu
gewinnen ja also genau diejenigen zu
gewinnen
sozusagen von bern wird seien sehr sehr
plakativ formuliert von deren
ausbreitung er zum teil zu wenig gelebt
dass ein phänomen und das teilt
natürlich mit verschiedenen anderen
politischen konzeptionen oder figuren
und das andere was was in dem
zusammenhang oder was was mich so
fasziniert weil weil sie bullshit
erwähnt haben ist es wirklich bullshit
wenn jemand einfach das sagt was andere
zwar tun aber nie zu sagen wagten zum
beispiel das berüchtigte waterboarding
das ist ja eine geübte folterpraxis der
usa die usa hat sich dann natürlich über
internationales menschenrecht und
völkerrecht hinweggesetzt
der mann hat schon einen geheimen getan
und frank sagt ja dass die usa hat die
kraftlose hatte macht oder hat das recht
das zu tun also tun wir es doch
wenigstens woran man ist ja obama haben
alle für eine kleine erlöserfigur
gehalten aber grund dann aber hat er
auch nicht geschlossen trotz aller
versprechungen und dort wird
wahrscheinlich auch weiter gefoltert
das heißt also da habe ich sozusagen
diese form von porsche großer
ehrlichkeit und weiß ich nichts auch
wogegen ich sein
wenn wir noch einmal zum phänomen des
populismus zurück kommt vielleicht auch
nicht ganz mit ihnen ein ich bin es gibt
ja schon gewisse dinge die man an
populisten sehen kann sondern ich denke
die treffen auf so viel populismus
klassisch ist ja sozusagen eben diese
dieses gefühl sich von der elite nicht
mehr repräsentiert zu fühlen genau sich
zu wehren gegen die politische und dann
gibt es sowohl links wie rechts
verschiedene formen des populismus im
linken populismus ist sozusagen der
kampf gegen die kapitalisten die oben
sind die arbeitnehmer die sich
entrechtet fühlen und die kapitalisten
an der macht wären währenddessen im
rechtspopulismus sehr viel stärker diese
idee eben der der der erlitten
da ist die da im parlament sitzen und
nicht das machen was eigentlich das volk
will stark auf natürlich auch ethnisch
begründet ausländer gegen inländer
sozusagen wenn man diese skizze noch
einmal aufmacht dann stellt sich ja die
ganz wichtige frage warum krankt die
repräsentative demokratie so sehr
woher kommt diese tiefe
politikverdrossenheit die uns ja schon
auch in europa angst machen muss
ich finde das stichwort sehr gut weil
ich eigentlich auch gerade auf den punkt
kommen wollte ich glaube wirklich mehr
als ein clown oder ein populist wirklich
eine ein symbol oder ein symptom für
sozusagen eine verdrossenheit an einem
system repräsentativer demokratie und
ich glaube das sind gewisser weise ist
ja ganz konventionell was sie erwähnt
haben wie kommt es dass gerade die die
die sozial benachteiligte arbeiterklasse
sie für so jemanden begeistern kann
das ist das prinzip der republikanischen
partei schon ganz lange das erstaunt
nicht dass glaube ich auch dieses dass
er gewisse dinge offen ausspricht und
sozusagen diesen an thetis tischen zug
hat das ist das grundprinzip
amerikanischer politik jeder
präsidentschaftskandidat der es
irgendwie so drehen konnte dass er nicht
dem establishment zugehört hat es getan
inklusive obama das ist ein grund mit us
amerikanischer politik dass man nicht
zum establishment gehören darf das sind
so das sind motive die bei jump
irgendwie auch ganz konventionell sind
ich glaube was er wirklich zeit und ist
es eben auch wir haben wir vorher die
fragen ernst nehmen es ist gibt ja auch
wirklich umfang die zeigen es gibt auch
sehr viele unterstützer trans die nicht
ernst nehmen es geht wirklich um dieses
lustvolle heraufbeschwören eines
chaotischen falles also die licht sagen
wir finden
rechts sondern einfach sagen ich möchte
mal sehen was passiert wenn ich den
wählen und dieses das ist so seien also
dass man und also natürlich ist das auch
eine art und weise brandgefährlich dass
man dermaßen politik und demokratie
verdrossen ist dass man sagt wir
probieren jetzt einfach mal aus wie das
ist wenn man das an die wand fährt ja
und völker und gehöre weil so dass nach
der punkt von historiker norbert frei
der betont hat dass diese
politikverdrossenheit eben implikationen
hat die ganz ganz gefährlich sind und
zwar deswegen weil sie die
traditionellen maßstäben der politik
kann nicht obsolet machen
man kann nämlich einfach lügen erzählen
es spielt überhaupt keine rolle mehr
was zählt ist alleine die show und die
show ist auch diejenige die eben
medienwirksam vermarktet werden kann
also möglichst zitierfähige social media
häppchen
ist das nicht auch ein standardargument
dass ich seit jahrzehnten höre immer
dann wenn tatsächlich jemand auftaucht
der offensichtlich unter den etablierten
politischen kräften gewisser weise
bedrohlich zu werden scheint sogar dann
wenn er ohnehin dazu gehört das gehört
natürlich dazu wird sind keine
wirklichen außenseiter von unten oder
von sonst wo sollte gerne genau zu
diesem statement und schaffen es dann in
ihrer rhetorik sozusagen sich hier
kritisch oder oder oder
als außen vor zu positionieren aber das
gehört doch auch sozusagen zu dieser zu
dieser art wäre halt oder an dem gegen
sagen sobald jemand sofort zu ihrem und
auftaucht der der wie sie völlig recht
ich sage im grunde ohnehin auch dem
konventionellen bild über weite strecken
entspricht also gold zu holen und auf
sieht sieht man sofort der demokratie in
die highlands ist seit sie das immer so
sieht man die demokratie die
politikverdrossenheit ich will ganz im
gegenteil sagen dass so emma und gerade
in seiner buntheit in seiner provokation
ja weil er uns eben auch nachdenkt aber
dazu bringt die für fendt nachzudenken
wenn europa zitiert und thomas hobbes
zitiert um
donald trump zu verstehen das ist eine
belebung des politischen diskurses und
auch in amerika wieder diskutiert wird
auch innerhalb der republikaner
das ist sozusagen etwas was man nicht
dass politikverdrossenheit kriegs fast
den eindruck sie sind richtiggehend
begeistert überhaupt also das ist ja
wenn sie von der belebung sprechen also
sie sehen keine gefahr
naja ist noch nicht noch mal dass
präsidentschaftskandidaten nominiert ja
ich weiß auch nicht unterschiedlich sein
werden würde und wer hat was ihr denkt
werden würde halte ich sozusagen die
rahmenbedingungen und der amerikanischen
demokratie für stark genug dass er nicht
mehr unheil anrichten kann als
amerikanische präsidenten also gehen wir
schon angerichtet haben ich darf nur
darauf verweisen dass eine
wahrscheinliche konkurrentin hillary
clinton mitverantwortlich war als
außenministerin für jenes disaster im
vorderen orient den wir jetzt jene
flüchtlingskrise zu verdanken haben
unter anderem über das man eingangs der
sendung diskutiert haben
herr kassel schätzen sie seien der ganze
populismus ist es für sie ein
populistisches phänomen ist es
übertragbar auf europa ich meine es gibt
unterschiede und es gibt ähnlichkeiten
ich glaube man kann das nicht so absolut
sagen ich glaube auch dass wir in europa
sonst manchmal leichter fällt solche
figuren wenn sie weit weg in den usa
sind klar als populisten und schickt hat
so endläufen wenn man das dann mit den
eigenen leuten macht wird ein bisschen
heikler und ja so christoph blocher der
haupt doch eigentlich schon mit den
menschenrechten und so also ich glaube
es geht es gibt eine leichte tendenz
dass wir eher tendenziell das problem
bei uns unterschätzen und darum dass wo
überschätzen
aber ich glaube schon dass dieses
erstarken von ob man sie jetzt
populisten nennt oder nicht irgendwie
einfach deutlich macht dass quasi freie
waren alleine langfristig kein grund für
den demokratischen rechtsstaat sind
sondern dass man halt immer wieder neu
dafür kämpfen muss das eine politische
kultur weiterhin funktioniert und dazu
würden für mich auch minderheitenrechte
gehören es gab in dieser abstimmung über
die durchsetzung initiative ihren der
schweizer dieses schöne zitat ja
demokratie ohne rechtsstaat das ist wenn
neuen füchse und eine ganz darüber
abstimmen was es zum abendessen gibt
und in dem sinne würde ich einfach es
würde ich sagen ich glaube auch nicht
dass wir jetzt unmittelbar vor dem autor
beträgen umsturz stehen in den usa
aber das phänomen traum erinnert doch
wieder daran dass es irgendwie wichtig
ist immer wieder neu für eine
funktionierende demokratische kultur zu
kämpfen
es wurde ja auch gesagt wir sind
sozusagen überhaupt diese wähler oder
sie begeisterten vom tram punkt wir
haben schon darüber diskutiert das sind
eher personen die ich als verlierer
sehen zum beispiel verlierer der
globalisierung auf verlierer der
digitale die jungen sie sehen ihre jobs
bedroht
es sind vor allem im übrigen ja auch
weiße männer
also da hat der chefredakteur des global
ist hat darauf hingewiesen dass
wahrscheinlich ist auch eine tendenz
gibt zu sagen bloß keine frauen da macht
also auch eine angst davor dass eine
frau in den usa das ruder übernehmen
könnte aber wurde im ganzen hintergrund
finde ich auch sehr interessant dass
trump oft so etwas also etwas gesehen
geht wie ein repräsentant des american
dream
der selfmademan der hat unternehmer ist
er verschweigt aber dass ein
dieses gesamte geld geerbt hat also
seinen wahlkampf logo besteht ja darin
zu sagen self an die kampagne bezahlt
alles aus eigener tasche
warum funktioniert diese linke die ist
ja so eklatant dieser dieser mythos
funktioniert auch bei und somit das von
selfmade moment funktioniert überall ja
ich kann nur erinnern wir haben so ein
mini tramp der auch in österreich gehabt
denn frank stronach also diesen der auch
im unternehmen aufgebaut hat wirklich
selber aufgebaut hat weltweit
operierenden autozulieferer konzern und
der auch glaubt er kann jetzt in die
österreichische politik einsteigen
ebenfalls als eine dieser schillernden
figur auch da war im ersten moment
relativ große zustimmung grad auch bei
verlierern und der hat es geschafft er
zeigt es geht der kampf und nach wenigen
noch wenigen jahren ist absolut
ernüchterung eingetreten ja also ich
glaube diese american dream ist einfach
so anschlussfähig für die amerikaner das
ist vielleicht auch deren kulturelle
identität der von kulturell werten reden
also das wäre das ist halt so ein tiefes
mythisches muster dass das immer
funktioniert ich wollte vielleicht noch
zu jump anmerken
da wir jetzt auch gerade einen tweet
gesehen haben in gewisser weise ist
krank der perfekte proponent dieses
internet social media twitter zeitalters
weil er nie fährt einen tritt pro minute
also der ist sozusagen in dieser kurzen
polemischen nicht durch argumentierten
form ist ja natürlich super weil er
eigentlich nur oberflächlicher sätze
liefert und das internet ist ja genau
dieses medium das stellen wir bei gerade
auch bei der debatte die wir vorhin
geführt haben über flüchtlinge das ist
eine problematische smid und die
sozialen netzwerke weil in dieser
polemischen verkürzung in dieser ellipse
in diesem nicht mehr den platz haben für
argumente sondern nur noch den platz
haben für stichworte und anfeindungen
ist das internet genau dieses problem
hat dieses problem und ich glaube jump
repräsentiert genau diese art von
abschüssigen pfad auf dem der
öffentliche diskurs zum teil zu sein
scheint sehr gut weil es sich einfach
unfassbar gut in sehr kurzer zeit
zitieren lässt zugleich und da bin ich
ja wenn man jetzt nochmal fragt nach der
anschlussfähigkeit eine europäische
populisten also was ich ja sehr mutig
entfernt aber was sind der schweiz jetzt
passiert ist mit der durchsetzung
initiative weil da hatte man durchaus
wiederum den eindruck dass gerade die
auch die sozialen netzwerke und aber
durchaus auch andere öffentliche foren
dazu genutzt wurden und gegen eine
populistische politik wieder so etwas
wie einen vernünftigen argument
basierten öffentlichen diskurs
einzuführen und es muss ich gestehen
wenn ich über die populismus debatte der
letzten jahre nachdenke finde ich
eigentlich fast eines der
hoffnungsvollsten beispiele dass wir
jetzt hatten also dass tatsächlich eine
öffentlichkeit wieder diskutiert und
nicht mehr sich nur auf diesen vorschlag
war und ja ich ja in diesen dass es
vielleicht ein gutes stichwort um noch
einmal vielleicht auch auf die ganze
stunde zurückzublicken nämlich sich die
frage zu stellen wie einen wir auch
gespaltene gesellschaften wieder weil es
kommt natürlich im rahmen dieses
populismus in vielen ländern also denken
ja auch an deutschland die afg wird
wahrscheinlich im nächsten wahlen
relativ viele stimmen machen viele
prozent der einfachen das macht das
finden auch angst und in diesen
gespalten ländern stellt sich die frage
wie kriegt man das wieder zusammen und
in der durchsetzung initiative war
sozusagen dieser ganze gegen winter
entstanden ist breit getragenen links
wie rechts aus ganz vielen
unterschiedlichen lagern haben sich da
stimmen informiert deswegen zeigt meine
letzte frage auch
herr ließ man die kann denn diese diese
tiefe tiefe kluft in vielen ländern
wie kann die wieder in eine
verständigung wenden
ich denke es sind vielleicht zwei ebenen
der bab 8
das eine ist tatsächlich gäbe dass des
diskurses das heißt dass man eben nicht
nur auf die sozialisierten verkürzten
ebene
wir sind gerade in social video
bereichen sehr oft stattfindet sich
reduzieren lässt sondern tatsächlich die
argumentative auseinandersetzung sucht
auch mit dem das meinung man nicht teilt
das hat ja ganz wichtig es ist kein
öffentlicher diskurs wird alle gegner da
der ärztlich zusammensetzen und ihre
ängste gegenüber df bekunden aber nicht
mit deren komponenten von denen einige
jetzt sicher diskussionsfähig sind
diskutieren vielleicht nicht alle das
heißt also diese ebene denke dass dieses
drängen darauf tatsächlich zu
argumentieren und nicht nur reflexartig
bekenntnisse abzugeben wir ganz ganz
wichtig und das zweite ist natürlich
eine gesellschaft wenn man sich schon
als gespalten sieht das ist diese
gespaltenheit ist ja nicht nur ein
oberflächen- phänomen es gibt an der
basis genau diese sozialen konflikte es
gibt die verlierer es gibt die menschen
ob das jetzt immigranten sind oder die
die hier im job verlieren
die schlechte aussichten haben und die
sich offensichtlich von bestimmten
teilen der elite des politischen
establishments einfach nicht wahr nicht
aber nicht vertreten fühlen sollen nicht
wahrgenommen fühlen ja und ich denke
ohne diese sozialen konflikte zu lösen
das heißt auch ohne eine andere form von
wirtschafts und sozialpolitik wird mir
nur auf die diskurs ebene diese
differenzen nicht aufheben können
vielen dank an dieser stelle sind wir am
ende erst mal der diskussion angelangt
nicht anwendet ihre sendung wir wollen
nämlich dieses diesen philosophischen
stammtisch jeweils abschließen mit
philosophischen tipps jeder von uns
bringt jeweils ein buch mit einem film
eine ab ein hinweis auf eine ausstellung
irgendetwas was philosophische
tiefenschärfe erlaubt sie alle haben
diesmal bücher mitgebracht frau mag was
ich ihr tipp ich habe carlos frenkel
betreut und in palästina mitgebracht und
auf eine art und weise zeigt er
vielleicht auch genau diesem weg den wir
suchen für eine öffentliche debatte
das ist nämlich jemand ein professor in
kanada
deutsch brasilianer da durch die welt
gereist das philosophische salons und
diskussionen veranstaltet hat immer mit
religiösen menschen und mit versuchten
mit religiösen menschen vernünftig
philosophisch über religion zu reden mit
erstaunlich guten ergebnissen auch weil
er sich auf die mittelalterliche
jüdisch-arabische philosophie bezieht
und es auf die genuinen eigenen
traditionen des nachdenkens das
vernünftige nachdenkens über religion
und eben mit einem sehr großen
optimismus auch dahinter geht zu sagen
philosophie als vernünftiges diskussions
element ins vernünftiger diskussions
technik auch kann uns wirklich
weiterhelfen wenn wir helfen wenn wir
grundsätzlich unterschiedliche meinungen
haben die meinung können unterschiede
bleiben aber wir können trotzdem drüber
reden also ein tipp für ein buch noch
einmal ein buch von ihm ja ich möchte
das buch catchen capital.de pics of tax
competition von peter ditsch empfehlen
dieses buch geht diesen verschiedenen
formen von steuervermeidung und
steuerwettbewerb auf den grund jetzt den
einzelnen staaten zu nehmen deswegen ein
gerechtes steuersystem aufrecht zu
erhalten und das buch noch dann auch
vorschläge wie diesen problem durch
internationale regulierung beizukommen
ist ein schönes beispiel dafür was im
besten fall herauskommt wenn sich
philosophen mit ökonomischen themen
befassen und ist allen sehr zu empfehlen
die sich für fragen der globalen
gerechtigkeit interessieren besser um
das natürlich auch politischen
entscheidungsträgern hier in der schweiz
wir hoffen sie nehmen es ernst das
letzte buch im buch ja ich habe ihr tipp
ich habe ein buch ausgewählt auf das wie
man vielleicht jetzt auch schon bemerkt
haben wird ich lange gewartet hat ein
buch des bedeutenden sophie historikers
und gelehrten kurt flasch mit dem titel
der teufel und seine enkel die neue
biografie
es ist eine wunderbare philosophische
inspirierte kulturgeschichte dieser
figur des teufels also diese inkarnation
des bösen ausgehend von den anti
orientalischen wurzeln dieser figur über
die rezeption weiterentwicklung im
christlichen mittelalter über goethes
mephisto bis in die gegenwart spannt
sich dieser faszinierende bogen und die
provozierende schluss these dieses
buches ist gott und teufel
billen eigentlich eine einheit ich werde
wenn ich den teufel los werden will
auch im wortwörtlichen sinn gottlos und
das ist glaube ich eine ganz starke und
diskussionswürdige these vielen dank ich
selber bringe einen tipp mit für einen
philosophischen blog es ist slippery
slope sein philosophisches magazin
umsonst frei zugänglich im internet sie
ist ein philosophischer blog von jugend
philosophen aus deutschland die
verschiedene alltagsphänomene
diskutieren auch politische fragen
aufnehmen in jüngster zeit waren dass
beispielsweise terrorismus firmen
philosophien im moment wird da gerade
geblockt und gestritten über das halten
von haustieren durchaus immer mit viel
witz viel ironie auch hie und da viel
schwarzem humor witzig zu lesen und sehr
informativ ja alle diese tipps findet
man auch bei uns auf der website phasen
und das nachlesen möchte etwas von
diesen büchern konsumieren möchte und
damit sind wir tatsächlich jetzt am ende
des ersten stammtisch angelangt wir
haben den rat von shampoos 8 uhr nicht
befolgt wir haben mehr gesagt aus guten
morgen ich glaube es hat sich gelohnt
das war ein bisschen mehr als
unvernünftig sondern durchaus denke ich
ein beitrag zur debatte
vielen dank dass sie hier waren sieben
tanks diskutieren die nächsten
philosophischen stammtisch dieser art
gibt es am 24
april die themen werden wir wiederum ein
paar tage vorher bekanntgeben und wir
freuen uns wenn sie uns im vorfeld auch
wieder ihre ideen dazu schicken
wer sich mit der literarischen seite der
flüchtlingskrise auseinandersetzen markt
den empfehle ich den literaturclub vom
nächsten dienstag wo unter anderem das
buch der stunde von abbas khider mit dem
titel ohrfeige diskutiert wird jetzt
gleich reisen wir in der sternstunde
kunst zurück in die usa und zwar mit dem
film der die geschichte einer
aufmüpfigen frauen wenn der zeit während
der reagan und bush senior probte die
bands den feministischen aufstand machen
sie sich also bereit für ein stück
bühnen revolution und genießen sie den
sonntag
[Musik]